we've got academy award-nominated actor
director and writer kenneth brana he
turns the camera on his own life in his
new film
belfast it's a coming-of-age movie based
on his childhood in that northern irish
city
amid deadly violence there it's told
from the point of view of a young boy
named buddy and it focuses on his
family's difficult and very relatable
decision about whether to leave
or stay in the only home they've ever
known my family
i think medal wants us to leave belfast
what do you want
every night before i go to sleep when
the santa purse i ask god if he'd fix it
so that when i wake up in the morning
i'm the best footballer in the world
then i also ask him as well
that when i grow up can i marry
catherine
even if she loves ronnie boyd but you
could still see him but you'd marry me
that's what i want
and kenneth branagh joins us now uh
kenneth congratulations on a beautiful
movie thank you very very much so i
second that emotion thank you guys
a gorgeous piece of workshop in all
black and white uh effectively one
family's story uh in a country's story
uh it's called the troubles probably the
more understated terms for 30 years of
violence sure
can you talk about for people who don't
know the situation and i would include
myself among them
what was going on in your childhood that
you're now putting on screen well it's
complicated but in the mid to late 60s
around the world you know in paris there
were riots in san francisco as a summer
of a lot of social and political
agitation in belfast there was civil
rights activity which spilled out onto
the streets and starting from a good
place but ending in a difficult place
which essentially split itself up into a
tribal conflict if you like between
protestants and catholics in the case of
our film we lived in we were nominally
protestant we lived in a street with
catholics and the film starts with the
beginnings of that kind of violence
where a protestant mob marks the houses
of the catholics who were then forced to
leave and that kind of thing was
happening all over the city at that
point and it's been pointed out that
long before you made this movie you in
interviews referred to what happened in
your childhood in belfast as sort of the
trauma that made you
and then the pandemic hits we all go
into a kind of isolation and lockdown
and all this trauma came back up can you
talk about that well you're right i mean
isolation and trauma and introspection
there was a lot of silence at the
beginning of the lockdown the planes
stopped flying the traffic was quieter
into my brain came the sounds of belfast
and this moment really the moment that
changed my life where a mob came up our
street and in those 20 seconds where
everything kicked off um the where i
lived how i was going to sound what i
was going to do whether i was ever going
to end up sitting sitting opposite you
in this studio all of that changed and
it did so in a dramatic way that
meant that our family
experience and everyone around us
experienced great deal of sorrow and an
extraordinary amount of joy as well and
ultimately the film is very joyful but
it's about finding your way through very
very difficult decisions that many
families have to face and how did it
change you because i look at little
nine-year-old buddy who was able to find
joy in all of this trauma and all this
volatility and the relationship with
your parents then having to move from
the place that you clearly didn't want
to go as a little boy but your parents
were looking at the big picture yeah
well you know like many parents they
make sacrifices for their children it's
a big it's a big um decision to make but
i think uh what you learned was when
maybe we learned some of this in the
lockdown is to relish this the precious
time that you may have not necessarily
time that you you banked on having but
time when you can think about what it
means in terms of your relationships to
parents and and family and extended
family i came from a place where the
idea that it takes a village to raise a
child was something that was so it gave
you such security uh when we moved away
there was this sense of being slightly
lost and in a way i felt subsequent to
this moment in my childhood that i sort
of lost my way and the film is a sort of
a way to come back home part what's so
beautiful about the film and you say
takes the village but really like the
community is just your street it's so
local which i think would be very
relatable to a lot of people and you
were telling us earlier then in your
actual life when you were a boy there
just a few streets away other boys your
age were dying yeah and on that very
same day august the 15th 1969 so it's
not a fantasy it did happen it was the
beginning of 30 years of
you know what you might even more sort
of
properly called the sorrows not the
troubles because it contained such
such difficulties for the people of that
region but miracles have occurred since
it's it's an an imperfect and fragile
piece but an amazing journey across my
lifetime has happened in that part of
the world peace has to be re-won every
day but some of the lessons that we
learned then for me it's it's a thrill
that people around the world seem to be
recognizing them moments of conflict or
displacement in their own lives means
that people from iran nigeria of haiti
have come up to me and said that's my
story tell me my story that's best of
all you mentioned the duality the pain
and the joy i mean this is a deeply
personal story what do you want people
to take away from this film
well i hope that they can uh look at
their own lives and and maybe as i tried
to go back and shake hands with the
nine-year-old kid who was doing the best
he could and so uh so were his family
and i think uh
the uh the the preciousness of the time
that we have and the preciousness of all
those cliched sounding things but love
between uh family members support the
ability to try and and the belfast
people really do this and the film
really tries to do it as tough and as
dark as it gets you've got to find a way
to laugh or find some humor or
brightness you've got to put one foot in
front of the other and in so doing you
know respect your fellow man and try and
get on with making a better world today
is not so cliche after all and you said
if your parents were alive you wouldn't
have made this movie but i would think
they'd be
very proud yes kenneth of what you've
given to us absolutely very kind to say
hi
well i do appreciate it i know that they
would be very very pleased with the
actors who we cast as them because my
mother particularly would think oh she
dances just like how how i like to dance
and my dad would not have been uh
unhappy about being cast by jamie dornan
i was surprised you weren't able to care
about love i'm surprised you weren't in
the movie well on the subject of family
i think if you want to be arguing with
your family uh at home about who the
best picture of the year uh should go to
you're going to want to see this film
because it's going to be running yes yes
well we we should see oscar oscar buzz
well an audience is what we'd love so if
you want to come that would do it that's
all you need to do argue about it later
i won't worry about the nominations all
right kenneth braun thank you very much
thank you we should point out you're
also going to be on the late show with
stephen colbert tonight so we look
forward to that belfast the movie we've
been talking about is in theaters
tomorrow only steven's not as fun as us
but
go ahead have a good time